A philosophy of ORAL SEX
It has to do with loneliness and self-disgust
When we begin as babies in this world
if we're lucky, everything about us is acceptable and adorable, from our toes to our temples
Then gradually we grow up
and become shamed of our nakedness and guilty about so much
it becomes taboo to touch and be touched
we have no choice but to keep a minimum of 60, or even better, 90 cm distance
between us and others at all times
but deep inside, we never quite forget the needs with which we were born
to be accepted as we truly are
in every area
hence the significance of oral sex
it sounds disgusting when we think of doing it with an innapropriate person, and that's the point
Nothing is erotic that isn't also, with the wrong person, revolting
But with the right person
at the precise juncture where disgust could be at its height
we feel only acceptance
welcoming permission
The privileged nature of a relationship is sealed by an act which with someone would've been sickening
Oral sex is interesting and exciting because it's about closeness
Normal life continually requires us to be polite so much of the time
We have to repress all that's ostensibly bad within us
our lust and our desires
We can't both be accepted by society and reveal who we really are
hence the erotic ecstasy
which is more accurately, really, just emotional relief
when oral sex permits our secret self with all its bad and dirty sides
to be witnessed and enthusiastically endorsed by someone else
The bond of loyalty between a couple
grows stronger with every increase in explicitness
the more unacceptable our behavior would be to the larger world
the more we feel as if we're building a haven of mutual acceptance
Sex liberates us for a time, and that punishing dichotomy between dirty and clean
It literally purifies us by engaging the most apparently polluted sides of ourselves in its games
We can press our mouths, the most public and respectable aspects of our faces
eagerly to the most contaminated parts of the other
Thereby symbolizing a total psychological approval
much as a priest would accept a penitent
guilty of many transgressions
back in the fold of the church with a light kiss up on the head
The pleasure of oral sex is deeply rich and significant
It isn't primarily about a pleasant physiological sensation at all
it's about psychology, acceptance and a promise of an end to loneliness